fil out the window for
me you want me to fly with
you okay the only you it will be on
YouTube tomorrow I
know
same y
go oh
just hey so like if we ever get out of
this do you maybe like want to go out on
a date
no hurt too hey guys why you leave me
out like
that hey guys what are you doing down
there no nothing we're just hanging
out getting in your way
no wouldn't want to be on I
probably see see you here we go here we
go Hing up the
plane
almost
se's how about some of
this or this this is what happens when
you go anywhere with just Dan Eric just
normal table Oh no just
kidding just kidding we have a terab
hard drive here we have an iPhone this
little guy this was in there oh that's
in there what's that this is coffee I
don't know if they have it where you
come
from what is what is this thing you have
here this is the glass okay a stir stir
is that what that is we're going to
Cancun with American Eagle ooh
I didn't even know what I was turning
around for but it was totally worth
it I don't I don't really know the
words